hier soir m6 diffusait une toute
nouvelle émission opération renaissance
un programme produit réalisé et présenté
par karine le marchand autour de dix
français en obésité morbide qui
souhaitait tout tenté pour perdre du
poids pour la première fois la
télévision
nous avons suivi pendant plusieurs
années le parcours de neuf femmes et un
homme dans leur combat contre l'obésité
avant même sa diffusion l'émission avait
soulevé de nombreuses critiques
notamment sur la banalisation des
pratiques de chirurgie bariatrique pour
réduire l'estomac des patients une
émission qui pour certains présentent le
surpoids systématiquement comme un
handicap et la minceur comme une
finalité ce soir marine téléspectatrices
du programme et sur notre plateau pour
nous expliquer pourquoi l'émission l'a
beaucoup choqué alors qu'elle suscitait
plus de commentaires déjà merci marine
d'être là mais les marines faut vous
dire qu elle est vénère douvrin marina
on va voir déjà premier extrait ce qui a
suscité le plus de commentaires c'est
que l'émission sous-entendez
régulièrement que pour être heureux il
fallait être mince au regard des
quelques mois elles ont perdu entre 40
et 70 kg et découvre le bonheur de vivre
en bonne santé
enfin une bonne nouvelle je vais me
débarrasser de se voir entre définissiez
après je crée complètement épanoui
grâce à une gamme spécifique elodie
découvre avec plaisir comment mettre en
valeur sa nouvelle silhouette tu obèses
est souvent parce qu'un problème
psychologique
non non on va avoir une action mécanique
qui va permettre de les faire perdre du
poids le gros globe le mince match
les gens qui sont en surpoids ou obèses
sont des gens qui gobent donc ils font
ça va marine je sais que vous êtes vous
allez regarder l'émission hier vous êtes
témoin du jour vous êtes vous êtes hors
de vous pourquoi alors en fait déjà le
problème avec cette émission c'est qu'on
s'intéresse encore une fois aux
personnes obèses ou en situation
d'obésité ou des personnes grosses on
les appelle comme on veut que quand on a
besoin de maigrir
ça non on ne fait pas des missions moi
je propose un conte viennent chez moi et
qu'on voit la vie que je mène je suis en
situation d'obésité
j'ai 24 ans je suis épanoui dans ma vie
j'ai un travail et je le pense vraiment
je trouve très jolie mois merci beaucoup
mais voilà en fait c'est aussi le
problème c'est l'impact que va avoir
cette émission les propos grosso fob
qu'on va avoir
et puis dans cette émission en ce qu on
peut remarquer c'est que on infantilise
vraiment en fait la personne grosse
parce qu' elle ne sait pas prendre en
charge toute seule elle sais pas maigrir
elle s'est passé mais donc on va faire
une prise en charge totale de la
personne alors bien entendu ce que je
veux absolument dire est qu'on ne
déforme pas mes propos c'est que je ne
suis pas du tout contre 7 c'est les
chirurgies bariatriques et je ne suis
pas contre ces personnes qui ont
aujourd'hui participer à l émission très
loin de là et j'espère qu'aujourd'hui
elles vont très bien mais la facture
alors il ya une séquence qui vous
interpellez c'est celle d'un médecin qui
explique quelque chose regarder ça c'est
la phrase qui ressortit de l'émission
grand gaube le mince match
les gens qui sont en surpoids ou obèses
sont des gens qui gobent donc ils font
ils avalent et le mince lui il va
machine alors pourquoi c'est important
tout simplement parce que quand on mâche
et bien on va activer des signaux de
satiété qui sont extrêmement importants
pour ne pas reprendre du poids alors ça
ça c'est la presse qui vous a choqué moi
et c'est la phrase qui m'a choqué parce
que je trouve ça extrêmement choquant
d'entendre encore ça en 2021
j'honore 2021 oui tout à fait c'est très
c'est très choquant en fait d'entendre
ça parce que qui vous dis que moi
aujourd'hui je gobe mais je gagne mes
aliments sains alors à priori blumarine
tout va bien dans votre vie tout va très
bien dans ma vie c'est pas de fiancé les
gens cherchent à d'accord on a monté l
idée d depuis 63 ans lors des
présentations dont les candidats ont
leur présentons les présentes avec leurs
noms l'orage et leur poids ça vous a
choqué aussi
alors après quand on dit choqué
peut-être que le moins gros parce que
forcément c'est le thème de l'émission
parlez de du poids et que c'était bien
sûr mais normal qu'il est présent est-ce
que moi là aujourd'hui je me présente à
vous bonjour marine 24 ans elle taille
tel poids et puis
ben moi j'adore manger du fromage non
bout d'un moment le dire moi si je me
présente aujourd'hui je me présente en
tant que personnes heureuses et
épanouies dans ma vie et voilà mon
métier qui est aujourd'hui aussi je dois
le dire je travaille énormément au prix
aussi des enfants parce que je suis
éducatrice spécialisée auprès des
enfants et des adolescents justement sur
la grossophobie d'accord sur tout ça est
justement cette émission elle met en
lumière toutes les stigmatisations et
toutes les discriminations qui peut y
avoir autour des perses alors façon
devait il y avait des témoignages aussi
très fort avec beaucoup d'émotion
notamment quand stacy est revenu sur son
parcours est évoqué ce qu'elle a dû
traverser quand elle était petite
regarder pendant toute son enfance celle
ci a subi la maltraitance de toute sa
famille et l'humiliation au quotidien
mon frère et ma soeur m'a sauté de veau
aux rachats vasseur a dit que je peux
faire les concours de sumo elle avait
dit que c'est adopter donc moi je
croyais masse avez vous enfin ils sont
tout maigre santé a pas bah oui et amen
oui elle va tout et tout le temps la
maison c'était toujours décrit
des crises mais tous les jours tout en
notant des conneries alors oui kelly
alors moi j'ai adoré l'émission je crois
moi j'ai adoré l'émission
après je peux comprendre ce que tu en
penses toi mais j'ai pas trouvé ça
gelly me trouvais ça même bien pour les
gens que ça peut aider en moi j'ai une
cousine qui est justement a subi cette
opération une fini philippe vive c'est
sa finition ce livre voilà et ben
justement elle était contente de voir
cette émission voir comment les autres
réagissent à et ça l'a aussi aidé de le
regarder
alors pourquoi pas prendre le bien de
cette émission de laisser ce qui est
négatif est ce qui vous déplaît parce
que c'est vrai que dans une émission
elle est longue
après les longues c'est vrai il ya des
intervenants qui disent des choses
choquantes moi ce qui m'a choqué ce qui
m'a choqué dans cette émission c'est
quand la soeur lui a dit oui en gros
maintenant c'est maigre
je t'aime je suis d'accord mais à ce
moment-là prenons le positif de cette
émission pour les gens qui on eu besoin
catharines moi ce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que le souci avec cette
émission c'est qu'on ne parle pas de
l'après chirurgicale et 13 à 6 ans à
redon et on est là la représentante de
l'état et les représentants de la
tutelle de brice taton
mais on ne parle pas on fait on idéalise
vraiment la chirurgie et moi je suis la
femme la mieux placée pour en parler
aujourd'hui puisque moi-même j'ai été
opéré d'un anneau gastrique en 2016 et
le susie qu'on idéalise avec
l'hypnothérapeute le psychologue je ne
sais quoi encore qu'on voit c'est
totalement faux en fait en cours via
passa alors peut-être que oui il ya pour
certaines personnes effectivement il ya
des il ya des suivis après l'opération
et bien heureusement mais pas pour cent
pour cent de la population
alors alors qu'on attendait tous aussi
dans l'émission marines et les dans les
émissions de transformation ces deux
avant d'après après c'est vrai que ça
vraiment on tout le monde me regarde je
pensais vraiment je vous dis ça fait 1
millions 1,9 million téléspectateurs
j'étais persuadé que ça allait cartonner
je sais pas pourquoi ça part bien
beaucoup mieux marché que ça on va voir
les extraits d avant après et nicolas
pernikoff vous allez me dire votre
sentiment puisque vous êtes le
spécialiste média de ces vingt dernières
années en france
en menant le plus grand combat de leur
vie contre l'obésité et le diester ci se
sont découvert des ressources et un
courage qu'elle ne soupçonnait pas de
quoi être optimiste pour l'avenir
sans jamais oublier d'où elles viennent
un gain
[Musique]
c'est beau ouais c'est bien c'est beau
oui est-ce qu'elles sont mieux
maintenant c'est ça oui c'est ça arrive
c'est vous vous êtes heureuse tout à
fait son service justement c'est pour ça
que je suis là aujourd'hui et c'est pour
ça que notamment sur les réseaux et sur
mon instagram marine pleut ça ils ont
vraiment jeu je prône la bientraitance
et la bienveillance de prendre soin de
son corps et bien sûr je ne prône pas
l'obésité c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il faut
entendre en fait alors sur les réseaux
sociaux ça a été un des fermes dont
nicolas oui c'est clair que ça devient
juste d'ailleurs si je pense que c'est
le mauvais format en fait ce que
j'aimais bien c'était à l'époque de la
rue qui suivait jours après l'accessoire
des gens qui avaient un vrai problème au
niveau psychologique au niveau médical
et havrais un vrai suivi et c'est un peu
ce que vous dites là où moi j'étais très
mal à l'aise j'ai regardé toutes les
missions c'est vrai que je m'attendais à
un truc énorme
un peu genre relooking extrême ch
américaine ou à avancer
j'étais mal à l'aise bah oui c'est ça
qu'on a mais j'étais mal à l'aise
surtout alors sur le côté psychologique
et le pen mulhousiennes n'ont même qui
me met pas les ours annoncé les plus
sombres a regardé du tout à ce que
certains disent que j'ai dansé gros
nécessairement envie de le voir et quand
tu n'es pas grosse est en bois
laissez pas les appels à la chérissent
et une irizar dont un chez moi je suis
le programme depuis cinq ans alors déjà
sur la sincérité de caries non les mots
on aime pas mais elle est totalement
sincère moi je l'aï vu pleurer mais
autour de certains entretiens donc là je
peux pas tolérer qu'on dise qu'elle
n'est pas sincère là dessus maintenant
les jeunes femmes fut désolé c'est des
jeunes femmes qui avaient commencé le
processus s'est pas les missions qui les
a incités à c'est elle même qui avait
commencé le processus à tripoli les
caméras ont fait et en plus pas que les
caméras et a trait au contraire le
gouverneur garçons la semaine prochaine
le seul garçon du programme il parle de
son mal-être je suis tombé dans alger qu
on les suit pendant trois quatre ans
après on les laisse pas en déshérence
après l'opération pourrait demander à
savoir il est alors lorsqu'on dit peu
jusqu'à ce que vous disent attention
c'est que aujourd'hui
et notamment grâce aux recherches qui
ont été faits par la station gras
politiques qui ont d'ailleurs fait une
tribune
tu veux absolument aller lire ce que
vous comprendrez pourquoi cette
opération est juste juste marine sur ce
cas d'élise injustement maladie qui a
dit les personnes qui s'occupent qui
sont voisins qui sont concernés n'ont
pas envie de regarder et les personnes
qui ne sont pas concernés disent pas je
suis pas concerné j'ai pas envie de
regarder ça vous êtes d'accord c'est
entièrement faux parce qu on est
totalement conscient fait que le je
pense que les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui en situation d'obésité sont
conscients qu'ils sont obèses donc on a
en fait on fait ça vous avez regardé
savons pas mais moi j'ai regardé juste
pour forcément réagir avant tout
téléspectatrices nan moi non je regarde
je regardais plus avoir de pouvoir parce
qu'on s'intéresse effectivement qu aux
personnes en situation de d'obésité
quand il faut maigrir on s'intéresse pas
autrement qu'à eux
juste pour le fait de me griller une
pression autour des personnes en obésité
ces deux maigrir voilà même qu'on a vu
les pubs pendant cet opus cette émission
opération renaissance c'est des pubs
avec des programmes de minceur des
choses comme ça et on fire devrait être
aussi ce qu'avaient également commencé à
nommer les séries à notre sujet qui a
beaucoup fait parler
c'est le voyeurisme du programme en est
ils ont filmé les participants
absolument tout le temps ton tantôt
temps par convaincre certains de parties
siècle ils ont fouillé partout partout
regardez ça regarde on vous tiens
voyager déplaire quand je serais si j'ai
mon public je déteste lahoud trippant
les gens là sont dégueulasses
c'est le petit madoff
un tablier c'est la peau du ventre qui
recouvrirent carrément tout public
il
[Musique]
jeux belote tombe le blog de partout la
bagarre ça
ça et le pire alors karine le marchand a
répondu à toutes les critiques
c'était chez nos amis de c'est à vous
regarder ce qu'elle dit karine le
marchand à toutes les critiques qui lui
sont faites
jugé par des gens qui n'ont pas vu
l'émission on le rappelle oui mais bon
écoutez moi je commence à être habitué à
la polémique
je pense que jusqu'à présent ne donne
pas la parole aux obèses à la télévision
française ne sont pas représentés ni au
cinéma ni la télévision ni dans les
émissions ou si peu soit on ne fait rien
et effectivement barcarès à tête des
petits n'enfants et et on ne suscite
aucune polémique alors sophie koch non
mais effectivement je peux comprendre
qu'il ait une forme de gênant ça un
moment donné dans cette émission je
trouve le propos très très intéressant
et très bien et effectivement ce sont
des personnes qui sont en situation un
peu de désespoir qui avait commencé ce
processus
m6 et accompagnement pourquoi pas et ils
ont la chance vous dites vous par
exemple vous avez une chirurgie vous
n'avez pas eu d' accompagnement
psychologique
là on espère qu'un accompagnement
psychologique après il ya des séquences
effectivement c'est quoi cet
accompagnement psychologique avec
cristina cordula en fait ma demande est
possible mais moi je les adore c'est lui
mais moi j'adore que j'avais encore de
lavage mais quel est le propos ils ont
donné de mettre ces jeunes femmes comme
ça en face à millénium se propose c'est
à dire qu'on doit juste ça on les voit
dans ces grands gérants sont comme moi
je suis désolé de ne pas l'avoir compris
le projet j'ai passé moins de 7 sec mais
quand elle dit on donna mais jamais la
parole aux obèses elle ne lui a pas
donné ils n'ont pas donné la parole aux
sommets vierges qui n'ont pas partie ils
ont fait l'émission vous avez raison si
les chantiers qu'ils ont fait une
émission de divertissement qui peut avec
des mécaniques d'avant après jusqu'à la
petite boîte à la fiche avec sa ceinture
j'ai trouvé ça mais gênant ce détail en
suisse qui fait ça c'est pas le bon sens
marine marine depuis ce qu'il faut
absolument comprendre c'est que quand on
dit aux données la personne donnée le
parole aux personnes obèses qui vaille
au risque d'accord ok mais ce qu'il faut
absolument comprendre aujourd'hui c'est
que on peut être bien dans son corps en
étant en soupe chaude visite je vis
heureuse aujourd'hui je suis l'open oui
dans ma part et je sais qu'il faut
absolument plus comprendre parce que il
va y avoir d énorme impact et je pense à
toutes ces personnes qui sont mal dans
leur peau et qui ont regardé c'était
cette émission et qui vont se dire et
bats la solution pour moi c'est de me
faire opérer sauf que les nantais face
est de mise en garde
le sondage à ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs oui à 33% et l
grossophobie à 33% tenons à 67% en tout
cas marine moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ne changez rien vous avez
l'air extrêmement heureuse vous êtes
magnifique je vous dis à mon avis vous
allez recevoir beaucoup beaucoup de
téléspectateurs qui nous ont dit ce soir
et je peux vous dire vous allez avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de messages sur un
site